[Music]
let's go to charlie in tampa what's up
charlie
hey john here rachel how are you all
doing today doing great thanks for
calling
good um well i have a question about uh
my wife and i have two children we have
a 15 year old boy an eight-year-old girl
and um you know they've seen us in their
lifetime on you know the ramsey plan and
doing our steps and even the oldest um
his envelope system when he
you know got a small allowance as a
younger kid well this summer he has his
first full-time job just during the
summer
and uh he's you know making his first
paycheck he actually just got this past
friday
and um
i want to mention tithing to him he's
yeah his reply was yeah of course i'm
going to give something to the church
but was teaching him the 10 standard his
eyes got kind of wide because based on a
little 20 allowance here and there
that's a very small amount but when he's
looking at the 100 paycheck you know
that's a lot of money at first so the
question is um i just assumed that you
know we would require him to type being
you know his parents and him leaving our
home and following our example um my
wife's not at all opposed to that but
she brought the the possibility of him
being able to make the decision for
himself and just wanted to see what you
both thought on that
yeah it's a great question um
you know when it comes to giving i think
whether you're a parent teaching a child
or it's yourself
i
the legalistic side always rubs me the
wrong way so i'm always we encourage 10
percent at ramsey and i believe i we
tied 10 percent even more winston myself
um so i believe in it 100
but i i don't do it because it's a rule
and it's an obligation uh there's a
heart change that occurs when it comes
to giving and so for him
um
you know i i think it's it's a great
exercise for him to learn to give period
right because you want to teach your
kids the things when they leave home
become adults of like here are the
habits here are the principles and the
values that i want to instill in you as
you know as a parent to a child so when
you leave home that almost this is
normal this is this is how you do life
and so giving is one of those things for
me so giving is non-negotiable now to
require 10
out of every paycheck for him
um
i don't know i mean
part of me is like i think it's kind of
up to you as the parent to decide what
it was and i was thinking with mom at my
parents when we got an allowance we did
have to give yeah because we got like
six bucks or whatever a week when we
were kids and it was like yeah you gave
a dollar it wasn't quite 10
and you know
they were not very legalistic about it
uh and then when i got when i babysat
and worked at the mall and all of that
as a teenager
i did give out of it but i honestly
cannot remember charlie if mom and dad
made us do the ten percent um so for me
it's less of a math issue and more of a
heart issue for him and i want him to
have the heart of a giver when he leaves
home and not just like the mathematics
of i give ten percent and that's what i
do does that make sense
it does no that's a good point more of
the spirit behind it that i want to
encourage as a parent here's here's how
it's how we do it in our house charlie
and very similar
is
i think two guiding principles here
number one uh rachel says that that more
is caught than is taught
and so i think this is he's old enough
now to sit down with you guys and do
your family budgets together
hank um is my son's 12th he probably
sits through one out of every three or
four budgets now and he rolls his oh
gosh
sorry dude you got to sit down and watch
us do this
i want him to see that the first line in
our budget is giving and we've got you
know tithing but we've got places where
we give i want him to see this is how
mom and dad roll with their money he's
watching it happen sometimes we let him
hit the button to send payment x or
whatever that or this got automatically
drafted so we're showing him this is how
we do this
the second thing is is i do think it's
important to
like as there's a reason why
you're you're still the steward you're
still a custodian of that money right
you're still in charge of your kid and
so in our house we've said you will give
to something
giving is non-negotiable
if at this age in your life you are not
choosing to give here but you're going
to give there i'm going to let you make
so that's where the that's where the
decision-making capability is so he's
going to see my son is going to see
we give to this particular organization
that we believe in we tie them this way
so every sunday morning hey the lights
are on here and the air conditioner
works here and
our pastors can get up on stage and feed
his family because we give
you will give but you're going to give
somewhere so that's where that latitude
comes in does that make sense because
i'm with rachel the last thing i want to
do is have a son who is counting dollars
in this on a spiral notebook
that he was forced to quote unquote
giveaway to a thing he doesn't you see
what i'm saying
no that's a good point um you know very
very good to see that that perspective
you know we both have no doubt that he
is a very generous young man we've seen
that we just want to continue to promote
and encourage that and and no doubt that
he'll be blessed through that you know
as we are and he sees he sees that and
all the things that you know we're
blessed with and able to do because
that's no that's a very great point and
that's a good takeaway yeah and and one
thing too charlie with parents that uh
and obviously you and your wife have
done a fabulous job i mean from what
even you've said in this call like man
that's such good intentional parenting
uh when it comes to money and your kids
uh but i'm not saying this is you but
there are some people that listen to
this show religiously and they are they
are hardcore and it is like there's no
room for mistakes and we're going to
make the kids do everything perfect and
we got this
and while the motivation is good because
you're like i want my kids to learn this
i don't want them to make the mistakes i
made
you have to give room for mistakes for
your kids to learn on their own and so
it's better for them to make small
inexpensive mistakes under your roof
versus going out in the real world and
the first time that they make a mistake
uh you know that it's
that it's out there so i'm saying all
this say for for your son
say you guys said hey you have to give
but the amount you want to give we're
going to let you choose and let's just
pretend charlie he gives one percent and
he's like here's just a little bit
and then maybe another month he's like
oh man i i do feel like i really love
this thing that i'm giving you i'm gonna
give a little bit more and he starts to
learn himself the feeling of feeling of
wow what the joy of giving you know
brings in him and he's learning that at
15 versus it being a mandate of that 10
so and one quick side note i
i don't have any data on what i'm about
to tell you here's a decision i've made
and my wife and i've made our house
i've invited my son in to
he has a ballpark of how much money
comes into our house every month
and i i was left out of that
conversation growing up i had no idea um
and so i think that helps with
perspective when he says whoa whoa it
was way easier to put two dollars
in the i don't know the collection plate
whatever that looks when i made 20 bucks
it's hard to put 50 when i make
500
and you can say
yeah i make 75 000. here's what i'm
putting in right and so it helps norm
that scale right that question you're
asking it helps and again i know your
kid he could probably go run to school
and say can you believe my mom and dad
make this much we have had hard
conversations about don't talk about
money and this is the right way to do
this and let's be respectful and these
are private numbers et cetera but i've
just opted to yeah let him sit down and
say here's what's coming in and here's
what's going out i wanted to have a
picture of how the world works right yes
yes and that may backfire on me
no i don't think it will no
well
no i don't know i know in that fact yeah
that's uh
i think it's so good to show numbers to
a point
to to to your example of like okay
here's real world
and here's what this looks like and yeah
here's how much cable is comcast out of
our paycheck yeah those shows you watch
here's here's netflix and just and
they're seeing the dollars leave the
paycheck like literally uh i think is
yeah or it was it was the it was the
light bill was the one he saw it on the
counter
and he was like how much it was
staggering right to a middle schooler
you know however many hundreds of
dollars like
i couldn't wrap my head around that yeah
it's like when i tell you to turn the
lights off in your bedroom and it was
like oh
you know what i mean yeah when you crank
the air conditioner down to like it has
a cost to it right see mom and dad they
did that they shared certain things
specific numbers but they we never knew
how much they like maybe they just
didn't trust us yeah i wouldn't
i don't think they're like we're
absolutely not giving rachel any of that
information my son is so much more
trustworthy
exactly
but hey he is the important thing morgan
and a like i want to read it rachel said
grateful for your intentional parroting
and parenting if you want your kids to
start engaging in certain behaviors
remember they watch you way more than
they listen to you so if you want them
to be givers you be a giver you want
them to be generous you be generous how
you tip people how you love people how
you tithe and give if that's part of
your value system whatever that looks
like for you model it and be intentional
about teaching your kids